Musique douce
...
-Du coup...
On va faire un tour de table
pour se présenter, si ça vous va,
comme Djiby,
il connaît personne, encore.
Qu'est-ce que c'est,
La Lucarne d'Ariane ?
La Lucarne d'Ariane,
c'est une association.
Tu connais un peu
les chantiers d'insertion ?
-Oui.
C'est pour l'insertion
des personnes éloignées de l'emploi,
ou qui étaient
sous main de justice,
ou en détention,
et c'est pour favoriser
leur insertion
et l'activité économique, non ?
-C'est pas mal.
-C'est très bien.
C'est toute personne considérée
comme ayant une difficulté
à retourner à l'emploi.
Les personnes sous main
de justice ont, de facto...
des difficultés à retourner
au marché du travail,
pour plein de raisons
qu'on connaît.
-Chris ?
-Moi, c'est Chris.
J'ai fait
quelques formations, j'ai fait
une habilitation électrique.
-B0, c'est ça ?
-C'est ça, tu l'as fait aussi.
-Tu connais ça ?
-Je l'ai fait aussi.
-Dernièrement,
j'ai fait la SST,
en sécurité,
ce qui est pas mal.
Maintenant, j'aimerais bien
passer la formation
régie lumière.
-OK.
-Voilà.
-Moi, c'est John,
je suis technicien polyvalent
à La Lucarne d'Ariane.
Je fais du montage de scène,
de la régie lumière,
prochainement, peut-être,
de la régie son.
J'aime beaucoup l'événementiel,
la sonorisation à gros volume...
-Chris, il est ici depuis...
-5 mois.
-5 mois, merci,
et John depuis...
-Début juillet.
-Et donc...
-Moi, Djiby, 20 ans,
nouveau salarié
à La Lucarne d'Ariane,
j'ai déjà des "expériences"
dans le monde de l'audiovisuel
et ce qui m'a poussé à rentrer
dans le domaine de l'audiovisuel,
c'est, on va dire,
mon amour, un petit peu,
pour la musique,
tout ce qui est créativité,
j'aime beaucoup la créativité
et pouvoir m'exprimer
librement, du coup,
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi
l'audiovisuel.
-L'article 432 du code pénal,
c'est ça ?
La liberté d'expression.
-C'est ça.
Ils rient.
-On cite le code pénal,
maintenant ?
...
-Bienvenue.
-Merci.
-Là, il y en a un
qui va te dire...
On avait fait une inscription
à trois formations à l'AGECIF.
Celle-ci, "Produire, diffuser
et vendre un spectacle",
et la troisième...
"Construire un budget".
*-OK.
-On a fait plein de SST
étalées dans le temps,
on a des nouveaux
qui devaient arriver,
mais qui sont sortis de détention
deux mois plus tard...
*-Ca complique les choses.
-Ca a été un bazar.
*-Oui, vous, vos candidats,
c'est plutôt des personnes
qui viennent du monde, enfin,
qui ont été détenues...
-C'est que ça, en fait.
On est un chantier d'insertion
spécialisé là-dedans,
donc 100 % de nos personnes
accompagnées sortent de prison,
ou sont en mesure alternative,
ou en mesure alternative
à la sortie de détention.
*-Oui, c'est ça.
J'ai bien compris
que vous n'avez pas
de vision sur 2023.
-Non, comme ils sont
sur des contrats de 6 mois
et que dès qu'ils trouvent
un emploi,
ils sortent et sont remplacés...
En fait, la durée moyenne
dans la structure est de 10 mois.
Il y en a qui ne vont rester
que 6 mois,
d'autres qui ne vont rester
que 4 mois
et d'autres qui vont rester
un an et demi.
-Comme ça, à peu près ?
-Pourquoi tu fais comme ça ?
C'est marrant.
-Faut faire une boucle.
-Comme ça ?
-Si tu fais ça...
-Attends, je vais essayer
de le refaire pour t'expliquer.
-T'entoures, tu vois.
-C'est pas facile
parce que j'ai tellement l'habitude.
Là, je le tourne.
Le câble vient comme ça et je viens
juste le poser là, en fait.
-Ah, OK.
-Et en fait, pareil, là.
Vas-y.
Je sais pas pourquoi
tu fais ce mouvement-là.
Ils rient.
...
-Il me fait trop rire.
-Le Chris en action.
-Lui, il le fait
dans l'autre sens.
Tant que tu arrives
au même résultat...
-On est d'accord
qu'un point important
qui résume la vie d'un tekos,
c'est le roulage de câble.
C'est la base.
-Un newbie, il arrive, il fait ça,
tout le monde le voit,
tu vois.
-En plus, c'est un geste que tu peux
faire pour aider tout le monde.
Il y a 20 000 câbles à rouler,
en général.
-Et c'est bon esprit,
quand c'est en démontage,
que tu viens
et que tu roules les câbles.
-Autre chose qu'il faut qu'il sache
en arrivant dans une salle
de spectacle : les projecteurs.
A partir de là,
j'ai accès à mes projecteurs.
J'y ai accès parce que cette table
est reliée par ce câble, regarde.
C'est marqué derrière
que c'est du DMX.
Le DMX, c'est relié au bloc
et c'est un protocole.
Un protocole, tu vois
ce que ça veut dire, comme mot ?
-Oui.
-En gros, c'est une forme
de commande.
C'est-à-dire que le DMX
envoie des informations au bloc
pour lui dire :
"Quand je fais ça..."
-Tu fais ça.
-C'est vrai
pour tous les projecteurs,
que j'allume
les uns après les autres.
-Comment tu sais quel projecteur
correspond à quel...
-Tu fais comme ça.
-Tu les testes, tu cherches.
-Des fois, quand c'est
dans une bonne salle, bien carrée,
chaque circuit est noté,
donc quand on branche un projecteur,
on sait où on va le retrouver.
Ici, c'est un peu le bordel,
donc tu regardes...
-Tu peux te faire
un petit pense-bête ?
-Oui, quand t'arrives
dans une salle,
tu te fais un pense-bête,
ou tu mets un scotch
et tu notes :
"latéraux", "pare-latéraux"...
Tu vois ?
-OK.
-OK ?
Bon, ben c'est bon.
-On est opé ?
-Yes.
-Les employeurs,
je pense qu'il faut
les préparer à l'accueil.
Il y a
des problématiques sociales
et humaines qu'on peut pas nier,
qu'ils ont, parce qu'il y a
une destruction complète
de ce qu'ils ont été,
par la détention,
qui fait qu'ils sont
plus fragiles
et je pense qu'il faut faire
un travail sur ça avec les lieux
et aussi travailler à déconstruire
leurs gros a priori.
Ce que j'ai entendu
de ce qu'elle m'a dit,
c'est des problématiques
que tu peux rencontrer
avec n'importe quel salarié,
en fait.
Sauf qu'elle relie ça
avec la condamnation
de la personne.
Pour elle,
c'est lié au fait
que ce soit des personnes
placées sous main de justice.
Et cette confusion,
je la trouve dangereuse,
parce qu'elle ne veut
plus accueillir
une personne sous main de justice.
-C'est une injonction
contradictoire
qui nous est faite
dans le chantier d'insertion.
Il faut aussi que les employeurs
soient clairs.
Quand on prend
quelqu'un en apprentissage,
on ne peut pas avoir
les mêmes exigences qu'avec un pro.
On prend quelqu'un en apprentissage
pour des raisons économiques,
parce que souvent,
c'est un emploi aidé,
donc c'est plus facile
pour la structure,
et il y a des raisons...
Les régisseurs aguerris,
ils ont pas envie de se fourvoyer
dans des emmerdes jusqu'au cou
pour des prix où vous pouvez pas
les payer.
Que les employeurs
soient honnêtes avec ça
et essayent de construire
un accompagnement,
s'ils veulent vraiment employer
quelqu'un,
pour que ça se passe
le mieux possible.
-On parle de personnes
qui ont été privées de liberté,
mais aussi d'autonomie.
Il y a des choses qui sont
pour nous évidentes
et qui ne le sont pas pour eux.
Ils respectent assez bien
les horaires.
Pour les sorties,
j'ai jamais eu de problème.
Par contre, aucun n'avait
prévu un en-cas,
parce que c'est des trucs
qu'ils ont complètement oublié
de faire et d'apprendre,
pendant leur détention.
Il va y avoir des trucs
qui leur semblent venus de l'espace,
à nos salariés en insertion,
comme si quelqu'un apprenait
à la fois à jongler
et une langue étrangère.
On peut pas tout...
-Moi, je fais les deux,
c'est facile.
-Oui, tu fais du monocycle
en travaillant ton roumain.
Mais si on leur apprend
à être autonomes,
à anticiper,
ils apprendront à apprendre
et ce sera plus facile après
pour apprendre
des nouvelles fonctions,
des nouveaux automatismes
pour leur métier.
-Elle a raison,
apprendre l'autonomie,
ça prend pas 6 mois,
c'est très long, surtout
quand tu as eu un fonctionnement
où on t'a enlevé ton autonomie
pendant 10, 15 ou 20 ans.
-On est bien, là, non ?
-Non, il faut que le point chaud...
Je vais me mettre
au milieu du carré.
C'est là où la lumière
est la plus intense.
Il faut qu'elle soit
sur ma gueule.
Là, tu es trop en bas.
Faut que tu remontes.
-Attends 2 secondes,
je vais le baisser un peu.
-Chris, resserre ton faisceau,
il est beaucoup trop grand.
Tout à l'heure, on a presque réussi
à rentrer le rond dans le carré.
-Oui, mais là,
je touche quoi ?
-La mollette derrière
se tourne.
Mécanisme
-Ca a l'air bon.
-Oui, c'est pas mal,
mais mets le bleu.
Tu la mets à combien ?
-A 60.
-Tu la mets à 60, OK.
Mets l'autre, du coup.
-Elles se croisent.
-C'est un truc de fou.
Reste comme ça.
-On se met les autres ?
Musique élégante
...
-Décrivez une situation
associée à une émotion.
Vous l'écrivez en dessous
de la feuille.
-Je suis en train de chercher.
-D'accord, pas de souci.
L'idée, c'est d'arriver à décrypter
ce qui se passe à ce moment-là.
Noël, est-ce que tu veux commencer ?
-J'ai marqué :
"Pour la première fois de ma vie,
"je suis autonome
dans mon propre logement,
"un réel plaisir,
une grande liberté".
-D'accord.
C'est la première fois de ta vie
que tu es seul
dans ton appartement ?
-Que j'ai un logement.
-Tu as un logement, super.
-En autonomie totale.
-En autonomie.
Et alors, du coup ?
-Mes pensées,
c'était : une cuisine,
une douche,
un clic-clac
et mon matériel studio,
puisqu'il est dans un garde-meubles,
donc j'ai pensé à ça.
Enfin, la superficie
de la pièce,
si je pouvais...
-Mettre tout ça dedans.
-Comment agencer...
-Comment organiser
ton propre espace à toi,
ta petite cabane.
-Après, je me suis arrêté
à l'émotion.
J'ai ressenti une grande émotion
de bien manger
et de pouvoir pratiquer
de la musique.
J'ai ressenti des frissons...
-De la joie et du bonheur ?
-Oui.
-Enfin !
-Ouais.
La première fois que j'ai cuisiné,
que j'ai pris une douche,
que j'ai regardé la télé,
enfin voilà,
que j'ai pu sortir seul,
entrer et sortir seul
de l'appartement.
-Oui, donc c'est quand même
tout un univers qui s'ouvre pour toi
et devant lequel tu te dis :
"Waouh, waouh".
-Ouais.
-Mais maintenant, tu sais que...
-C'est un univers de liberté.
-De liberté.
Propos indistincts
...
-Je connais des gens
hyper bons en live, mais en studio,
c'est pas intéressant,
ce qu'ils font.
C'est très compliqué, ça.
-T'as une autre énergie.
-Je vais prendre un exemple...
Propos confus
Il y a des musiciens jazz,
tu les vois en live,
tu pètes un câble,
tu écoutes leur album studio,
tu te fais chier.
Tu vois ?
Bon, et inversement,
parce qu'en studio,
c'est un autre travail.
Tout ça pour dire qu'Ableton
est un super outil pour composer.
Après, l'outil, chacun l'utilise
comme il veut, OK ?
Je sais pas si vous avez vu,
mais à côté,
j'ai plein de sons.
*Grésillement
Des sons un peu comme ça.
*...
-Des bruits d'ambiance.
-Oui.
Ca peut être des boucles,
ça peut être...
-C'est de la magie.
-Des one shot... C'est utilisé
en musique électronique.
On peut recomposer en live.
*Musique lounge
Quand j'envoie ça,
j'envoie toute la ligne,
donc c'est très pratique.
Pour le moment,
je vous demande pas
de savoir composer sur Ableton,
mais de savoir ouvrir
une piste audio,
d'y mettre des sons et de préparer
à pouvoir les diffuser
en direct, d'accord ?
Parce qu'en théâtre,
on est en direct, OK ?
Ou même en danse, tout ça.
Ca va, ça ?
Enfin, "ça va",
en tout cas,
vous voyez l'idée, l'esprit ?
-Et tout ça, on va le préparer
avec les comédiens et les artistes ?
-Ah bah oui, ça se prépare.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a du temps
de création, de travail.
C'est pour ça
que quand on est en création,
on met des projecteurs,
on essaie des trucs.
Mon objectif,
c'est que dans trois mois,
quelle que soit
votre place,
même si vous faites plus de son
dans l'absolu,
on installe une régie
et vous êtes capables
de le faire en autonomie, OK ?
-J'avais vu une annonce,
je crois que c'était pour Disney,
ouais,
et en gros quand j'ai vu,
il y avait des choses différentes,
mais après, c'est plus régie.
Moi, là, c'est plus technicien,
alors j'ai fait en sorte que...
C'est vrai que je peux changer aussi
quelques compétences,
je peux en ajouter...
-Il faut l'adapter
à la fiche de poste.
-Ouais, c'est ça.
Après, j'ai pas les...
J'aimerais être
technicien lumière,
je sais pas, moi,
dans un endroit
où il y a peu de personnes.
Par exemple, s'il y a 10 personnes,
je vais pas aller travailler.
-Pourquoi ?
-Non, mais te bloque pas...
-Pourquoi avoir
de telles exigences ?
En plus, dans la culture
et l'événementiel,
quand tu veux pas travailler
45 heures par semaine,
il y a des semaines où ce sera 60,
d'autres moins,
parce qu'il y aura un gros événement
où tu travailleras jour et nuit.
Tu peux pas dire : "Je vais faire
mes 35 heures tranquille."
C'est pas possible,
ou alors tu fais un autre métier.
-Oui, mais quand je travaille,
il faut que ça me plaise aussi.
-Après, il y a deux choses...
-C'est pour ça
que je vais pas postuler à tout.
-Si, tu postules,
parce que je te dis...
D'abord, t'acquiers une expertise.
Et ça, c'est pas rien.
Tu montres
que t'es organisé, ordonné.
-Je vais postuler,
pas de problème.
S'ils m'acceptent,
je refuse,
parce que j'aimerai pas
le poste.
-Pourquoi tu dis
que tu vas refuser ?
-Je vais pas dire oui
si j'aime pas.
-Tu sais pas si tu vas aimer
l'entreprise avant d'y travailler.
Ca fait quelques semaines
que je viens un peu,
je t'entends toujours dire :
"Je cherche, je cherche."
Tu peux plus chercher
comme ça.
Tu passes à l'acte.
En gros,
tu fais des lettres de motivation
et tu les envoies.
-J'étais sur SOGo,
j'ai pas terminé.
Je fais plein de choses
en même temps.
Je suis complètement...
-Bah voilà.
Toi qui es organisé,
t'es désorganisé.
-Quand tu es arrivée,
j'étais déjà dessus.
J'allais regarder ça.
Après, tu es arrivée,
tu m'as pas laissé...
On fait trop
de choses en même temps.
Propos indistincts
-Après...
-Dans la boîte,
il peut y en avoir une.
-Si t'en trouves, fais en sorte
qu'elle soit alimentée.
-Voilà, elle est là.
-Par contre, ce qu'il faut,
c'est ramener des XLR Jack,
tu sais, on en a prévu,
en ramener
pour arriver jusque-là.
-OK.
-Joris, il nous faut quoi ?
Il faut ça pour relier.
On a des bons amplis,
normalement.
Faut aller aux amplis.
Tu dois avoir du speakon
derrière les amplis.
-C'est là, tac.
-Elles s'allument ?
-Attends.
-Attends, t'as relié les deux ?
T'as relié celle-là ?
T'es rentré dans quoi là-bas ?
-Je suis rentré
dans du XLR femelle.
J'ai mis du XLR mâle.
-Oui, mais en channel 1, 2 ?
-Ah !
-Juste pour être sûr,
si on a une galère,
qu'on sache où on est.
-Channel 2.
-OK.
C'est allumé,
il y a du courant,
tout est OK ?
-OUAIS.
-Alors attends,
bougez pas.
*Musique douce
-Les deux marchent.
-Non, la tienne marche pas.
-Vas-y ? C'est pas mal,
laisse comme ça.
-Elle a marché,
mais elle s'est éteinte.
-On va préparer une texture de fond.
Celle qui est toujours au fond.
Et tu vois, regarde, attends.
En fait, l'idée, c'est que ce soit
pas trop fort, juste suggéré.
*Texture de fond
Quelqu'un parle dans un micro.
*...
Tu vois...
Tu vois, que des petits événements
sur un fond comme ça.
Tous ces petits événements,
tu les mets sur une piste,
mais il faudra
que tu fasses de l'édition.
L'idée, c'est que tu les coupes
et que juste, ils passent.
On les entend à peine.
-J'en mets un sur une piste.
-Tu les mets tous.
-Après, j'essaie de...
-Tu les mets tous
et tu règles les distances.
On va s'écouter
le montage, du coup,
si ça vous dit.
*Fracas
-C'est ce gros truc-là,
mais un peu avant,
il y a le froissement.
Si on peut aussi entendre
le petit froissement avant,
c'est bien.
C'est vraiment tout micro.
Juste avant ce gros truc,
mais c'est bien ce truc,
il y a un petit truc
qui vient avant.
-C'est ça que tu veux entendre plus,
celui-ci, là ?
*Léger froissement
*Fracas
Juste avant, le tout petit ?
-Ouais, c'est ça.
Exactement, le tout petit
plus le gros qui vient après.
-Le gros aussi ?
-Ah oui.
-Tout avant,
c'est inutile ?
c'est inutile, c'est ça.
Merci beaucoup.
-C'était juste 12 et 18 ?
-Ouais, ces deux-là.
Super, merci beaucoup, Djiby.
-Pas de souci.
-Bon bah voilà.
-C'est bon ?
C'est bon ?
Renvoie le premier.
*Cliquètement
*...
-Je suis désemparée, ici, parfois,
et je déteste demander de l'aide.
*Musique jazzy
*...
-Quand tu me parles,
tu me parles pas de la même façon
qu'à Lou, qu'à Joris ou ton pote.
Ca, c'est la connaissance
de ce qu'est la communication
et comment soi-même
on communique.
Alors ?
-Au niveau de la communication,
c'est codifié,
au niveau du langage, donc...
C'est une communication formelle,
régie par des normes, on va dire.
Il y a une attitude,
posturale, verbale...
Il y a des formules...
-Là, t'es pas en situation...
-Ouais, je sais.
Clairement, à tout niveau.
Mais, je suis pas
dans une position formelle.
-Bah si. Là, on est
en position de travail. Tu vois ?
Je m'en fous que t'aies un ballon.
C'est pas la question.
Simplement, il faut considérer
que quand vous êtes là,
on est dans une relation de travail.
-Oui.
-Donc, entre collègues...
-Après, il y a une nuance
entre notre attitude en exercice
et celle en prestation,
où on n'aura pas directement...
-Oui, mais il faut
déjà s'entraîner !
C'est toi qui cherches du boulot.
Faut pas oublier.
Djiby, tu fais quoi, là ?
-J'écris des notes.
-Ton téléphone, il est où ?
Djiby éclate de rire.
Non, Djiby...
Franchement, t'as quel âge ?
On dirait ma petite fille, quoi.
Il est là... Tu crois que...
-Comme tu parles avec les autres...
-Bah t'écoutes, justement !
-J'écoutais aussi.
-Non. Non, non et non.
-Il y a différents types d'écoute.
-Ah.
-On peut écouter,
comme t'as dit tout à l'heure :
écouter sans forcément regarder...
-Qu'est-ce qu'on a dit quoi, là ?
C'est pas des devoirs,
c'est des exercices
qui permettent de savoir
comment on fonctionne.
Vais-je faire face
à mes problèmes ?
Est-ce que j'aime la nouveauté,
les nouveaux défis ?
Si je te demande si tu es logique,
tu répondrais quoi ?
-Je dirais "J'essaie",
mais c'est compliqué.
-Quand on te connaît, on dirait pas.
-Normal, j'ai beaucoup à faire,
à l'intérieur
ou à l'extérieur.
Là, par exemple...
Il y a tellement de choses que...
Franchement, tu m'aurais connu
15 ans en arrière,
je t'aurais dit :
"Y a ça et ça à faire."
Maintenant,
y a tellement de choses...
Je vais pas te dire :
"Oui, je sais, je suis logique."
-Tu le dirais, je te dirais non.
-C'est pour ça que j'ai pas dit
"Je suis logique",
mais "C'est compliqué".
-Qu'est-ce que vous appelez
les problèmes ?
-Tu vois...
l'incarcération,
ça casse ta tête.
Avant, tu retenais mieux,
tu réfléchissais mieux,
ton vocabulaire
était 10 fois mieux...
Pour moi, tu vois,
ton vocabulaire se dégrade de fou.
-Mais pour retrouver tout ça,
il faut s'y mettre.
Il faut bouquiner beaucoup.
Il faut lire pour retrouver
le niveau de langage qu'on avait.
Vous lisez pas.
-Moi, j'allais plus au cinéma.
J'ai visité des...
Comment ça s'appelle ?
-Des musées ?
-Comment ?
-Ouais, mais là...
-T'avais une vie de...
-Je me renseignais beaucoup.
-C'est triste,
ce qu'il dit, quand même.
-Pourquoi c'est triste ?
-Bah, parce que.
-Il devrait avoir envie
de le retrouver.
-Il a raison, dans ce qu'il dit.
Je comprends ce qu'il veut dire.
-Je comprends pas tout, mais vas-y.
-Je comprends.
Ca lui a mis une cassure.
-Exactement.
-Il y a un avant
et un après.
-Là-dessus,
je suis d'accord avec vous.
Maintenant,
si vous faites l'analyse
de ce que vous avez fait
et ce qui vous a conduits là...
-Ouais, mais ça...
Ca, c'est un autre truc.
C'est un autre truc, ça.
-C'est pas un autre truc.
-Si, si.
-C'est un autre truc ?
-Bah ouais,
ça relève d'un autre truc.
C'est pas "mélangeable".
En gros...
Je comprends ce que vous dites.
Ce qui vous a amenés là-bas,
qui vous a fait endurer ça
et qui a causé cette cassure...
-Ca fait partie de votre vie !
-Oui, je sais,
mais en gros, vous voyez pas
où lui il veut en venir.
-La réinsertion est pas difficile,
mais très difficile.
-Lui, il constate,
maintenant, à sa sortie,
que le avant-après est plus dur
que ce à quoi il s'attendait.
Des fois, c'est même pas
l'envie qui manque...
Les difficultés auxquelles
je fais face
sont plus puissantes
que l'envie qui m'anime.
-Ca te paralyse ?
-Bah ouais, ça me paralyse.
Musique douce
...
-Ce qu'on peut lui dire
à ce ou cette juge,
c'est que...
que toi, tu fais
tout ce qu'il faut
pour aller bien
et pour te réinsérer.
Mais ton frein, là, aujourd'hui,
c'est ce bracelet.
Donc, t'as vu le psychiatre...
Tu prends un traitement ?
-Oui.
Que j'ai arrêté vendredi, mais...
Elle est pas obligée de le savoir.
-Voilà.
Tu suis un traitement...
Enfin, voilà.
-A base de lithium.
-Un traitement "efficace" ?
Il ricane.
-Un traitement.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre, là ?
Il y a l'addictologue aussi.
Ca, ça va avec le psychiatre.
Donc, l'addictologue.
Tu recherches du travail ?
-Oui.
-"Recherche d'emploi".
-Je me suis inscrit
à une formation également.
Tu peux le mettre.
-Bah, c'est gén...
T'en as pas parlé.
-Non.
-Tu vois ? On a bien fait.
La formation, c'est quoi ?
-C'est une formation
pour la sonorisation Expert.
-Mais génial.
-A l'INA,
et ça commence en janvier.
-Ce qu'on va lui montrer,
c'est que toi,
tu fais tout ce qu'il faut
et que t'as besoin
qu'on te facilite la vie,
de pas avoir la charge mentale
du bracelet en plus.
-Une contrainte inutile.
-Une contrainte... Voilà.
Mais ça, on peut le dire.
C'est une contrainte inutile
parce que t'es pas du tout
dans l'optique...
Parce que t'es dans une optique
positive de réinsertion.
Donc c'est une contrainte inutile.
Je vais le noter.
Ils rient.
Tu vois.
Bon. Allez, à toi.
-Merci.
-Moi, ça fait pas longtemps
que je suis dehors.
J'ai passé plus de temps
en prison
que là, ce que je vis
à l'extérieur maintenant.
Donc, c'est compliqué
tous les jours.
Il y a des choses...
que j'arrive à gérer
et que je trouve magnifique.
Il y a d'autres choses que...
Voilà.
Problématiques et tout.
Peut-être, des fois,
je comprends pas.
Ou, des fois, je me perds
et après, je perds pied.
Je ne me concentre plus.
Et voilà.
-Noël, j'entends bien
les soucis personnels,
les trucs et les machins.
Ici, à la Lucarne,
comme je t'ai dit,
tu peux t'appuyer sur Lua
pour les résoudre un maximum.
Donc il faut
te détendre avec ça.
-Ce que je fais...
Ce que je pratique, là,
c'est de la sonorisation.
C'est ce que je fais ici.
Donc pourquoi j'irais pas
plutôt vers...
-La sono direct ?
-Bah ouais.
Vu que toi, tu as
des connaissances dans le son.
Tu sais faire tourner
une station audionumérique,
tu sais brancher un micro
et de le faire fonctionner.
Tu as quand même des bases.
Il faut pas te dire
que tu pars de zéro.
Tu as des compétences.
Il faut juste que tu les organises
en fonction de ce qu'on te demande.
Sur un plateau de sonorisation,
on va pas te demander
ton certificat de sonorisation.
Mais on va te regarder travailler :
brancher les câbles,
faire les retours,
gérer ma console.
On s'en tape complètement de savoir
si t'as fait une école de son.
L'avantage des métiers
du spectacle vivant,
c'est qu'on te juge sur pièce,
pas selon ta batterie
de diplômes.
Après, il faut être disponible.
Et surtout...
Il faut être fiable.
Ca, c'est...
Tu dois être là tel jour
à telle heure. Tu y es,
même si t'es au bord de mourir.
Non, j'exagère, mais tu vois.
-Si tu recall un preset qui n'a pas
de phase binaire dans les têtes,
le préaliment dans le sub,
il veut rien dire.
Effectivement,
c'est ça dont tu parlais.
Mais ça se passera
que dans les têtes
et certaines voies des têtes.
Tu fais d'abord
"reverse polarity".
Tu as remarqué ton 180
quasi partout.
Tu reviens in polarity,
t'es quasi in phase.
Tu mets un délai pur.
(-Putain...)
-Le sub te dit : "Je suis bien
en avance de 0,30 mètre."
Pourquoi c'est plus cool ?
Parce que j'ai tenu compte
des lois de la physique.
Si la célérité,
c'est la même,
déplacement d'un front
à vitesse égale,
si j'ai que 30 centimètres d'écart,
je mets pas un délai
qui correspond à un sub qui est
2 mètres en avant dans la salle.
C'est pas vrai, en fait.
C'est complètement logique.
Maintenant que je l'ai redit,
c'est plus clair ?
En fait, bien considérer
la position des sources
pour en déduire les stratégies,
c'est essentiel.
-On cherche pas le bypass ?
-Quel bypass ?
-Pour mettre
le réglage processeur
à la place du preset.
-Ca, de toute façon,
on va connecter
ma machine dessus
donc on pourra le changer.
On pourra le changer.
-Du coup, John,
t'avais une question ?
-Dans le user, tu peux custom
les quatre canaux de sortie ?
-Les quatre canaux de sortie,
c'est affecté à une X8 ou une X12,
ou alors en custom,
tu pourrais faire canal 1-2 X8
et canal 3-4 X12.
-OK.
-Ca se fait via le soft.
Quitte à perdre du temps
sur les logiciels,
c'est bien
d'écouter les choses.
Aligner un système,
c'est placer une sonde
à un endroit déterminé
pour régler une problématique.
Si tu places mal la sonde...
Ton alignement n'est valable
qu'au point de la sonde.
Où est-ce qu'on mettrait ce micro ?
-Exactement là où on entend
les deux systèmes.
-Elle était où,
la zone d'ombre ?
-Au niveau du micro.
Il faut le reculer un peu.
-On est en train de chercher,
pas de construire un truc
de manière absolue.
La première fois
qu'on a construit un gratte-ciel,
les gars ont dû se gratter la tête
avant de le faire.
C'est pas inatteignable.
Partez pas comme ça...
Sortez des carcans,
des habitudes.
-Eh ben bonjour.
Moi, je m'appelle Caroline.
Je suis dépendante.
Je suis là aujourd'hui
pour représenter l'association
Narcotiques Anonymes.
-Bonjour. Merci d'être là.
Moi, c'est Stéphane.
Je suis dépendant,
membre de l'association
Narcotiques Anonymes.
On est là avec Caroline
pour vous présenter l'association
et vous partager
nos expériences.
Je suis content que vous soyez là.
Ca me touche, en fait.
J'ai passé 10 mois
à La Lucarne aussi.
Voilà.
Nous, ce qui nous unit,
à Narcotiques Anonymes,
ce qui nous rapproche,
c'est l'état dans lequel
on est arrivés,
dans le désespoir total
et dans la souffrance.
Moi, je suis arrivé,
je sortais du placard,
ça faisait six mois que
j'étais sorti de la Santé.
J'ai mis à profit
ces 10 mois d'incarcération
pour rien prendre.
J'ai pas compris
ce qui m'arrivait,
parce que là, forcément,
mes émotions sont montées.
J'ai repensé à tout le mal
que j'avais fait,
tous les morts que j'avais laissés
sur le bord de la route
que j'avais pas pleurés
parce que je consommais.
Ca a été super violent.
J'ai pas honte de le dire,
j'étais en larmes tous les soirs
dans ma cellule,
parce que voilà, c'était un constat
sur le chaos que j'avais pu vivre
et ce que je m'étais fait vivre
pendant toutes ces années.
Je suis dépendant à tout :
au sexe, à l'argent,
à la came, au pouvoir,
au sucre, à la bouffe...
La cigarette,
c'est plus ce problème-là,
mais je suis dépendant à tout.
Je suis malade. J'ai une maladie
qui s'appelle la dépendance.
Si demain je vole une moto,
dans une semaine,
j'ai une cagoule
et une arme à la main
parce que si je me suis pas
fait arrêter,
j'ai besoin de monter.
Ca s'arrête pas.
Et quand je consommais,
c'était ça.
Je sais à quelle heure
je vais commencer à consommer,
je sais pas
quand ça va s'arrêter,
parce que ça s'arrête jamais.
Ca s'arrête quand je m'achève.
Je me finissais
avec de l'alcool, des cachets,
parce que tout seul,
j'y arrivais pas,
et il fallait que ça s'arrête.
J'ai 36 ans de consommation active
derrière moi, tu vois ?
Donc voilà. Aujourd'hui,
je répare des choses
petit à petit,
et ma vie va beaucoup mieux.
-Moi, j'ai amené de la doc.
Je vais vous montrer ça.
Là, c'est ce qu'on appelle
les listes de réunions.
Il y a toutes les réunions
sur Paris.
T'en veux ?
-Non, ça va !
Ils rient.
Je les connais !
Brouhaha
...
-Tout est branché,
normalement.
Il y a plus qu'à brancher le son
à la console.
-Oui, faire la connectique.
Je vais allumer le truc.
-C'est bon, l'audio ?
-Il y a trois qui sont branchés,
pour l'instant.
*-Tu te laisses traverser.
-Ouais.
...
-Là, je l'ai pas.
-18 ?
-Ouais.
...
-Alors...
Euh... Celui-là, tac...
Contrôle...
...
-Dès qu'elles sont en face,
on coupe en même temps.
-Oui. Vous les laissez faire
une espèce de petit défi
qui va durer
genre 15 secondes,
tu laisses 5 secondes
de musique et tu coupes.
...
*Mix de musiques
et de rythmes différents
*...
La musique s'estompe puis s'arrête.
(-Vas-y.)
*Il repasse le même mix.
(-C'est l'autre.
C'est l'autre.)
(-Tu t'es trompé.)
(-Je me suis trompé.)
(-C'est pas grave. Vas-y.)
(-Je le remets ?)
(-C'est quoi, le bon son ?)
*Musique hip-hop électro
*...
Propos indistincts
...
Applaudissements
Musique douce
...
-On fait un point sur Djiby ?
-Oui.
-Pour recontextualiser,
Djiby est en retard
à peu près de deux heures et demie
tous les matins
depuis des mois.
*-Et les après-midi.
-Voire les pauses
de l'après-midi,
c'est fort.
Hier, on était plus cool
parce que c'était la grève,
bien qu'il habite à un quart d'heure
à pied, mais bon...
Il est parti à la pause de midi...
-Et après, il est pas revenu
après manger.
Avec Joris, on a fait le point
des trois mois de Djiby,
et on avait mis le cadre
sur les retards,
en disant : c'est pas nous
qui faisons les lois
et le droit du travail,
mais quand tu es absent,
il faut soit que t'aies
un arrêt maladie et tu te couvres,
soit tu viens pas
mais t'acceptes
que tu risques d'avoir des sanctions
disciplinaires derrière,
et comme lui, c'est très récurrent,
c'est problématique,
soit tu viens,
mais t'es un minimum dispo.
Je pense qu'il y a
des vraies problématiques derrière,
mais il y a un truc
de maturité, de...
Il est pas trop disposé
à travailler, quoi.
-La sanction disciplinaire
après la mise à pied,
c'est le licenciement.
C'est une décision...
très lourde,
pour plein de raisons,
et du coup, j'ai jamais licencié
personne jusqu'à maintenant,
donc j'ai voulu
que ce type de décision
soit soumis systématiquement
au conseil d'administration.
Là, pour le coup,
je suis plutôt pour,
parce qu'il y a pas une once
de mouvement de sa part,
même un mouvement
à dire quelque chose,
à revendiquer quelque chose,
genre "j'y arrive pas",
"vos horaires me saoulent"...
Non, il se passe rien.
*-On peut acter clairement
qu'il ne travaille plus
chez nous, en fait.
Ce qu'on constate,
c'est qu'il n'est plus
au travail.
On peut pas garder quelqu'un
qui n'est plus au travail.
On va pas passer notre vie
à écoper un bateau
qui prend l'eau en permanence.
-C'est une frontière
pas toujours évidente
à comprendre.
On est là pour comprendre
leurs problématiques,
les aider,
mais pas tout excuser.
-Ca, c'est une complexité
du chantier d'insertion.
Parce que dans aucun travail
sur la terre
tu as une journée de travail
où tu es payé...
-Oui.
-...pour parler de tes problèmes.
Ca, ça crée une confusion.
-Mais Djiby, il a saisi
que la prochaine étape,
c'est le licenciement ?
Il sait qu'après sa mise à pied,
il a plus aucune chance ?
-J'aimerais bien le recevoir
bientôt,
mais la question, c'est :
quand est-ce qu'il va venir ?
-Oui.
-Est-ce que vous avez préparé déjà
cet après-midi...
Vous savez quelle entreprise,
combien il y a de salariés,
sur quel poste
vous postulez ?
-Ca a été écrit, oui.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
Asseyez-vous.
Vous venez candidater
sur le poste de technicien du son
chez nous, chez GTHP.
-Oui.
-Un peu plus fort,
s'il vous plaît.
-Euh... Vous m'avez fait
une lettre de motivation et un CV.
D'accord, je vois.
Le CV, vous dites avoir
20 ans d'expérience...
-Oui.
-... dans la maîtrise
du matériel de diffusion,
l'installation de processus sonores,
de captation et de montages son.
C'est bien ça ?
-Oui.
-Euh...
Dans quelles entreprises
vous avez travaillé
pendant ces 20 ans ?
-En fait, j'ai appris
en autodidacte.
J'ai le père d'un meilleur ami
qui effectuait
des soirées privées...
-D'accord.
-...le week-end.
Des mariages,
des anniversaires...
-Vous êtes spécialisé
sur des progiciels,
des équipements en particulier ?
-Oui.
-Dites-moi,
quels logiciels ?
-Euh...
Pro Tools, Logic, Cubase...
Enfin, j'ai commencé sur Cubase,
sur Atari.
Après, j'ai fait
plein de logiciels.
-Vous avez un bon niveau
de maîtrise, alors.
-Oui, ça...
Oui, franchement...
C'est maîtrisé, je dirais même
un peu plus au-delà de ça.
-Vous êtes disponible
à partir de quand ?
-Immédiatement.
Donc je suis motivé,
je suis disponible,
il y a aucun problème.
-OK. Qu'est-ce que vous pourriez
amener à l'entreprise ?
-Euh...
-Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous amener de nouveau,
de neuf, de...
de rafraîchissant,
de professionnel ?
-Actuellement,
à La Lucarne d'Ariane,
j'effectue des stages,
donc je travaille énormément
en équipe.
Même à La Lucarne,
on travaille en équipe.
On a aussi
des sorties théâtrales
avec un résumé en équipe.
Donc je suis souvent
en équipe.
J'essaye de m'adapter...
-OK.
-...et de donner
le meilleur de moi-même.
-Sur les hippodromes,
vous serez en petite équipe,
donc parfois,
vous serez seul.
-Oui, c'est ce qu'on m'a dit.
-En autonomie aussi.
Donc je voulais savoir
si vous êtes prêt
à être autonome.
-Oui, la...
-Dans la captation...
-Je pense
que je suis rapide aussi.
Elle tapote son stylo.
-OK, on arrête là.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
de cet exercice ?
-Ben piégé direct !
J'étais perdu.
-Ah bon ?
-Pour La Lucarne.
-Ouais, pour La Lucarne.
-Je sais pas
si vous pensez comme moi...
-Parle plus fort !
-On a fait
plusieurs associations
de réinsertion.
En parler, c'est pas bon.
-C'est vrai
que La Lucarne d'Ariane...
-C'est pour la réinsertion.
-Ils le savent.
-Oui, mais s'il se renseigne,
il a mon casier.
Il peut se dire :
"J'ai du coeur, je le prends."
-Chacun doit développer
son discours
personnel.
-Il t'a demandé tes qualités,
T'as beaucoup parlé
du travail d'équipe,
ce qui est bien, t'as dit
que t'étais capable de t'adapter,
et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde une offre d'emploi,
on peut regarder ce qui peut sembler
être les trucs les plus importants
et souligner des qualités
qui sont vraies
mais te dire :
quelles sont les qualités
les plus pertinentes
si on me le demande ?
-Ton argumentation,
il faut l'adapter à ce que tu sais
de l'entreprise, tu vois ?
Toi, t'as expliqué
ce que t'avais fait,
mais du coup,
il faut pouvoir...
transférer tes connaissances
dans un milieu particulier
à l'entreprise.
-L'été, on a un festival
qui s'appelle le TAT Festival.
C'est notamment à ce sujet
qu'on a imaginé
ce temps de rencontre,
puisque depuis l'an dernier,
on travaille
avec La Lucarne d'Ariane.
Donc là, on a quand même
pas mal de personnes de l'équipe
qui sont présentes,
et Doumé,
notre régisseur général.
-On propose des prestations.
Nos techniciens sont mis
à disposition pour...
Je ne sais pas,
vous avez un événement X ou Y,
vous avez besoin qu'on fasse
la sonorisation, la lumière...
On propose des prestations
de ce type-là.
-OK, mais quand ils viennent
en renfort,
puisque l'idée,
c'est de proposer des renforts,
c'est quoi ? C'est des roadies
ou c'est des mecs qui sont
déjà capables de travailler
sur une table de son ?
-Chris, par exemple,
il sait gérer une table en tradi,
il sait gérer
des projecteurs tradi.
Après, ils sont aussi là pour,
entre autres,
donner des coups de main
dans une équipe,
donc on va être très honnêtes,
ils sont en formation.
Après, il y a pas
que les compétences non plus.
Si on vous les propose,
c'est qu'on estime
qu'ils sont fiables.
-Il y a une grosse prépa,
tous les extérieurs à faire,
toutes les salles à préparer,
monter les loges,
et ensuite s'intéresser
aux plans de feu,
tous les projecteurs à trouver...
Enfin, il y a toute la prépa.
-Il y a pas que la prépa.
C'est le plus important,
mais il y a aussi la manutention.
J'ai passé les CACES,
et j'ai vu que tu avais
une nacelle...
-Une formidable nacelle.
-Ca, je l'ai passé.
Je les ai passés.
Tu peux me ramener
le plus gros camion,
j'arrive,
je te le pilote normal.
-Ca, c'est cool.
C'est pas mal.
-Quand ils sont aux lumières,
on leur fait passer le CACES,
en règle générale,
donc voilà.
-Tu veux être intermittent
après ou pas ?
Tu sais ce qui te tente ?
-Pour l'instant, la lumière,
mais c'est vrai que je veux...
prendre sa place.
Rires
-OK, d'accord !
Attention, Doumé !
-T'as bien raison.
Place aux jeunes !
...
-C'est quoi, comme lieu ?
-C'est la Ressourcerie
du Spectacle.
-OK. Trop cool.
-C'est situé à Vitry,
donc c'est pas très loin
de chez moi.
-OK.
-Ca supprime la contrainte
des transports.
-Ouais, c'est super.
-Ca va me faire du bien.
-Trop bien, et...
-Et du coup, ils font
de la récupération
de matériel sonore,
de la restauration,
de la mise en location,
voire de la vente.
-C'est parfait pour toi.
-Ouais, c'est nickel.
-Trop bien.
-Ce serait
une de mes dernières périodes
de mise en situation
professionnelle.
Si je peux en profiter
pour avoir
le maximum de connaissances
et de compétences possible...
-Après, tu vois dans le mail
les détails
de ce que ça implique pour eux,
mais en soi, c'est un peu
comme un stage gratuit.
Pour eux, c'est assez avantageux.
Ils ont aucune charge,
à part le fait de t'encadrer,
et pas juste te faire travailler
gratuitement.
Donc ce serait du 22 mai au 23 juin.
Un mois.
-Ouais.
-C'est trop bien.
C'est parfait.
Trop chouette.
-Là, ça fait un an.
Où est-ce que t'en es ?
Comment ça se passe ?
-J'ai beau lire,
mémoriser, enregistrer,
c'est un problème pour moi.
J'essaie d'être autonome,
mais même comme ça,
j'ai encore des difficultés.
-Tu te sens à ta place ?
Tu te sens bien
à l'endroit où t'es ?
-Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais.
Ouais, bien sûr. Je...
Des fois, quand je sais
qu'il y a des choses
que je peux pas faire tout seul,
j'essaie de les faire tout seul
par mes propres moyens,
et voilà, quoi.
Après, au moment voulu,
quand ils posent des questions
par rapport à la technique,
j'arrive à me débrouiller.
-Je trouve que
c'est plutôt encourageant,
ce qui se passe,
enfin, ton évolution depuis le...
Et surtout
les dernières semaines.
T'as chopé un peu le rythme,
t'as chopé l'idée,
t'as chopé pas mal de choses.
-Ouais.
-Franchement, je trouve...
Tu donnes du tien,
t'essaies de bien faire,
c'est quand même
des choses importantes.
-Pour moi, l'évolution,
c'est par exemple
faire un plan de feu.
Au début, je galérais, mais je vois
que je vais de plus en plus vite.
C'est là que je vois l'évolution.
-Ca veut dire que t'avances.
-C'est plus dans la pratique.
Plus je pratique, plus j'évolue.
-Après, t'as ton rythme
d'avancement.
On est pas tous pareils
dans ce rythme-là.
-Je me dis : bon ben
j'ai pas régressé, alors.
-Moi, je te trouve
de plus en plus fiable
et de plus en plus OK, et ça,
c'est vraiment trop cool.
C'est pour ça
qu'il y a pas de suspense
sur le fait que t'es renouvelé.
Par contre,
j'aimerais que le mardi, ce soit
ta priorité absolue maintenant
d'être sur les offres d'emploi,
et même, il faut aussi...
-J'allais y venir.
-...arrêter de croire
que vous allez devenir régie lumière
en première expérience.
Quand t'es en reconversion
professionnelle,
c'est normal de pas commencer
au même niveau
que des mecs qui ont 30 ans
d'expérience dans le métier.
-C'est là où il y a la difficulté.
D'accord, OK.
Musique douce
...
*-Euh... Alors...
Je vais avoir besoin
de réglages en...
Pas trop fort
au niveau des enceintes,
et pas trop fort au niveau du micro,
mais il faut que je garde...
-Un équilibre.
*-...un équilibre entre les deux,
parce que je suis en résidence
cette semaine,
j'ai pas besoin
que ce soit trop fort,
mais il faut que ce soit
quand même confortable.
-Est-ce que tu veux
un petit peu de reverb ?
Enfin, on peut voir ça après,
mais il y a de la reverb, sinon.
*-On va tester.
Je veux bien que tu me dises
ce que ça donne quand je parle.
Parce que je parle
entre les morceaux.
Reverb légère
Ah, si. Oui, d'accord. OK.
Non. Parce que je parle
entre les morceaux, donc non.
-OK.
Donc j'envoie la musique ?
*-Ouais.
*Musique douce
Est-ce que tu m'entends bien, là ?
Il y a encore de la reverb ou pas ?
-Non, je l'ai enlevée.
*-OK. D'accord.
*...
Est-ce que t'as...
T'entends plus quoi ?
Le son ou moi ?
*...
C'est mieux comme ça pour toi ?
OK. On va rester comme ça.
*...
Et moi, ça devrait aller.
1, 2, 3, 4. Ah !
*...
Ha !
Euh... OK.
*...
Ca devrait le faire. OK.
C'est bon.
-OK.
Musique douce
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA